[Musique]
1778 pourvu d'une végétation naturelle
luxuriante l'île Bourbon proposé à ses
premiers habitants peu de plantes
indigène comestibl c'est en particulier
à Joseph Hubert remarquable botaniste et
agronome à Visé du 18e siècle que l'on
doit bien des fruits et des plantes
actuelles en un seul voyage en
1778 il introduit de Maurice 126 espèces
végétales qui sont plantées dans le
Jardin du Roi appelé aujourd'hui le
jardin de l'État à
Saint-Denis né en 1747 à Saint-Benoît
Joseph Hubert s'est passionné pour la
botanique et l'agriculture sans être
allé à l'école après avoir fait la
connaissance de l'intendant et botaniste
Pierre Poivre qui a créé le jardin de
pomlemous à Maurice il entreprend
l'acclimatation de de plantes issues des
quatre coins du monde le géropier le
muscadier le Lechi le longani de Chine
l'avocatier le mangouan des molu l'arbre
àin de Polynésie et le jamalac
d'Indonésie entre autres homme des
Lumières il est aussi le premier à
expliquer l'origine et le fonctionnement
des cyclones on lui doit enfin la
création de la ville de Saint-Joseph en
1778 Joseph uber introduit dans l'île
126 espèces
[Musique]
végétales